The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So looking for a
way to understand
the universality of
phase transitions,
we arrived at the
simplest model that
should capture some of that.
That was the Ising model, where
at each site of a lattice--
and for a while
I will be talking
in this lecture about
the square lattice--
you put a binary variable.
Let's call it sigma i that
takes two values, minus plus 1,
on each of the N sites.
So we have a total of 2 to
the N possible configurations.
And we subject that
to an energy cost
that tries to make nearest
neighbors to be the same.
So this symbol stands for
sum over all pairs of nearest
neighbors on whatever
lattice you have.
Here the square lattice.
And the tendency for them
to be parallel as opposed
to anti-parallel
is captured through
this dimensionless energy
divided by Kt parameter K.
So then in principle, as
we change K we could also
potentially add
a magnetic field.
There could be a phase
transition in the system.
And that should be captured
by looking at the partition
function, which is obtained
by summing over the 2
to the N possibilities
of this weight that
is e to the sum over
ij K sigma i sigma j.
So that's easier said than done.
And the question was, well,
how can we proceed with this?
And last lecture, we
suggested two routes
for looking at this system.
One of them was to
start by looking
at a low-temperature expansion.
And here, let's
say, we would start
with one of two
possible ground states.
Let' say all of the
spins could, for example,
be pointing in the
plus direction.
That is certainly the
largest contribution
that you would have
to the partition
function at 0 temperature.
And that contribution is all
of the bonds being satisfied.
Each one of them giving
a factor of e to the K.
Let's say we are on
a square lattice.
On a square lattice,
each site has
two bonds associated with it.
So this will go like 2N.
Since we have N sites,
we will 2N bonds.
There is actually, of
course, two possibilities.
We can have either all of them
plus or all of them minus.
So there is a kind of
trivial degeneracy of 2,
which doesn't really make
too much of a difference.
And then we can start looking
at excitations around this.
And so we said that the
first type of excitation
is somewhere on the lattice
we make one of these pluses
into a minus.
And once we do
that, we have made
4 bonds that go out of
this minus site unhappy.
So the cost of going from
plus k to minus K, which
is minus 2k, in this case
is repeated four times.
And this particular
excitation can
be placed in any one of N
locations on the lattice.
So this was this
kind of excitation.
And then we could go and
have the next excitation
where two of them are flipped.
And we would have a
situation such as this.
And since this dimer can point
in the x- or the y-direction
on the square lattice,
it has a degeneracy of 2.
I have e to the minus 2K.
And how many bonds
have I broken?
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
Times 6.
And I can go on.
So this was a
situation such as this.
A general term in
the series would
correspond to creating some
kind of an island of minus
in this sea of pluses.
And the contribution
would be e to the minus 2K
times the perimeter
of this island.
So that would be
a way to calculate
the low-temperature expansion
we discussed last time around.
We also said that I could do
a high temperature expansion.
And for this, we use the trick.
We said I can write
the partition function
as a sum over all these
2 to the N configuration.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there a reason we
don't have separate islands?
PROFESSOR: Oh, we do.
We do.
So in general, in this picture
I could have multiple islands.
Yes.
And what would be
interesting is certainly
when I take the log of
Z, then the log of Z
here I would have NK.
I would have log 2.
And then there would
be a bunch of terms.
And what we saw was
those bunches of terms,
starting with that
one, can be captured
into a series where
the n comes out front
and the terms in the series
would be functions of e
to the minus 2K.
And indeed, when we
exponentiate this,
this would have
single islands only.
The exponential will
have multiple islands
that we have for the
partition functions.
So these terms, as we see,
are higher powers of n
because you would
be able to move them
in different directions.
When you take the log,
only terms that are
linear and can survive.
So this sum over
bond configurations
I can write as a
product over bonds.
And the factor of e
to the K sigma i sigma
j, we saw that we could
capture slightly differently.
So e to the K sigma
i sigma j I can
write as hyperbolic
cosine of K 1
plus hyperbolic tanh
of K sigma i sigma j.
And this t is going to be my
symbol for hyperbolic tanh
of K, so that I don't have to
repeat it all over the place.
So this is just rewriting
of that exponential,
recognizing that it
has two possibilities.
We took the cosh
K to the outside.
And if I'm, again, on
the square lattice,
I have 2N bonds so there
will be 2N factors of cosh K
that I will take
into the outside.
And then I would
have a series, which
would be these terms that I can
start expanding in powers of t.
And the lowest order I have 1.
And then we discussed what
kinds of terms are allowed.
We saw that if I take just one
factor of t sigma i sigma j,
then I have a sigma i sitting
here and sigma j sitting here.
I sum over the two possibilities
of sigma being plus or minus.
It will give me 0.
So there is a contribution
order of t if I expand that,
but summing over sigma i
and sigma j would give me 0.
So the only choice
that I have is
that this sigma that is sitting
out here I should square.
And I can square it
by putting a bond that
corresponds to this
sigma and that sigma.
This became sigma squared.
I don't have to
worry about that.
Then I can complete
this so that that's
squared and this so
that that's squared.
And so this was a
diagram that contributed
N this quantity t to the fourth.
Well, what's the next type
of graph that I could draw?
I could do something like this.
And that is, again,
something that I
can orient along the x-direction
or along the y-direction.
So there is a factor of
2 from the orientation.
And that's how
many factors of t.
It is 6.
And so in general,
what do I have?
I will have to draw
some kind of a graph
on the lattice where at
each site, I either have 0,
2, or potentially 4.
There is no difficult with 4
bonds emanating from a site
because that sigma
to the fourth.
Basically, those kinds
of things actually
will give me then the sum
over-- possibilities of sigma
will give me 2 to
the number of sites.
And then these
graphs, basically will
get a factor which is 2 to
the number of bonds in graph.
And then again, you
can see that here I
could have multiple loops, just
like we discussed over there.
Multiple loops will go
with larger factors of N.
The thing that we are
interested is log Z,
which is N log 2 cosine
squared K. And then I
have to take the log
of this expression,
and I'll call it g of t.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How did we get
rid of [INAUDIBLE] bonds?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this e to the K sigma i
sigma j has two possible values.
It is either e to the
K or e to the minus K.
And I can write
it, therefore, as e
to the K plus e to the minus
K over 2 plus e to the K minus
e to the minus K over 2
sigma i sigma j, right?
AUDIENCE: My question was--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I know.
And then, this became
cosh K 1 plus what
I call sigma i sigma j.
So when I draw my
lattice, for the bond that
goes between sites i and j,
in the partition function
I have this contribution.
This contribution is
completely equivalent to this.
And this is two terms.
The cosh K we took outside.
The two terms is
either 1 or 1 line.
There isn't anything
that is multiple lines.
And as I said, you
can make separately
an expansion in powers of K.
This corresponds to nothing,
or going forward and backward,
or going forward, backward,
et cetera, if you make an
expansion in powers of K. This
term corresponds to going once.
Essentially, this captures all
of the things that stay back
to the same site and this is
a re-summation of everything
that steps you forward.
So everything that steps you
forward and carries information
from this sites to that
site has been appropriately
taken care of.
And it occurs once.
And that's one reason.
And again, if you have
three things coming
at a particular site,
it's a sigma i q.
So these are completely
the only thing that happen.
But in principle, this is
one diagrammatic series.
This is one diagrammatic series.
But you stare at
them a little bit
and you'll see why I put
the same g for both of them.
On the square lattice,
they're identify series.
See that series had N
something to the fourth power,
2N something to the
sixth power, N something
to the fourth power, 2N
something to the sixth power.
The first two terms
are identical.
You can convince yourself that
all the terms will be identical
also, including
something complicated,
such as if I were to
draw-- I don't know.
A diagram such as this one,
which has 2 or 4 per site.
I can convert that to something
that had spins plus out here,
then it minus here,
minus here, plus here.
And it's a completely
consistent diagram
that I would have had in
the low-temperature series.
So you can convince
yourself that there
is a one-to-one correspondence
between these two series.
They are identical for
the square lattice.
As we will discuss, this is a
property of the square lattice.
So you have this
very nice symmetry
that you conclude that the
partition function per site,
the part that is
interesting, either
I can get it from here as
K plus this function of e
to the minus 2K or from the high
temperatures series as log 2
hyperbolic cosine
squared K. Plus exactly
the same function of tanh K.
This part of it,
actually, I don't really
care because these are
analytical functions.
I expect this model to
have a phase transition.
The low-temperature and the
high-temperature behavior
should be different.
It should be order at low
temperature, [INAUDIBLE]
at high temperature.
There should be a phase
transition and a singularity
between those two cases.
The singular part
must be captured here.
So these are the
singular functions.
So the singular part
of the free energy
has this interesting property
that you can evaluate it
for some parameter K, which is
large in the low-temperature
phase, or some
parameter t, which
is small in the
high-temperature phase.
And the two will be related
completely to each other.
They are essentially
the same thing.
So this property
is called duality.
And so what I have
said, first of all, is
that there is a relationship
between, say, the coupling tanh
K and a coupling that I can
separately call K tilde, such
that if I evaluate the
high-temperature series at K,
it is like evaluating the
low-temperature series at K
tilde, where K tilde
of K is minus 1/2 log
of the hyperbolic tanh at K.
I can plot for you what
this function looks like.
So this is K. This is what
K tilde of K looks like.
And it is something like this.
Basically, strong coupling,
or low temperature,
gets mapped to weak coupling,
or high temperature,
and vice versa.
So it's kind of like
this, that there
is this axes of the
strength of K going
from low temperature, strong,
to high temperature, weak.
And what I have shown is that
if I start with somewhere
out here, it is mapped
to somewhere down here.
If I start from
somewhere here, it
would be mapping
to somewhere here.
So one question to ask is,
well, OK, I start from here.
I go here.
If I put that value of k in
here, do I go to a third point
or do I come back to here?
And I will show you
that it is, in fact,
a mapping that goes both ways.
And a way to show
that is like this.
Let me look at the
hyperbolic sine of 2K.
Hyperbolic sines of twice
the angles, or twice
the hyperbolic sines of
K hyperbolic cosine of K.
All my answers are
in terms of tanh K,
so I can make this sine to
become a tanh by dividing
by cosh, and then making
this cosh squared.
So that is 2
hyperbolic tanh of K.
And then, there's various
ways to sort of remember
the identity for
hyperbolic cosine squared
minus sine squared is 1.
If I divide by c squared,
it becomes 1 minus t squared
is 1 over c squared.
So the hyperbolic
cosine squared here
is the inverse of 1 minus
hyperbolic tanh squared of K.
Now, for tanh K, we have this
identity, is 2 e to the minus
2K tilde.
1 minus the square of that.
If I multiply both sides
by-- e to the numerator
and denominator by e
to the plus 2K tilde,
hopefully you recognize this
as 1 over hyperbolic sine of K
tilde 2K tilde.
So the identity here that was
kind of not very transparent,
if I had made the
change of variables
to the hyperbolic sine
of twice the angle,
had this simple form.
So then the symmetry
between K and K tilde
is immediately obvious.
You pick one value of K, or
sine K, and then the inverse.
And the inverse of the inverse,
you are back to where you are.
So it is clear that this is
kind of like an x to y0 1 over x
mapping.
x to 1 over x mapping would also
kind of look exactly like this.
In fact, if instead
of K tilde and K
I had plotted hyperbolic sine
versus hyperbolic sine of twice
the angle, it would have
been just the 1 over x curve.
Now, just to give you another
example, if I had the function
f of x, which is x
1 plus x squared.
This function, if I
divide by x squared,
becomes x inverse 1
plus x inverse squared.
So this is, again,
f of x inverse.
So if I evaluate this
function for any value like 5,
then I know the value
exactly for 1/5.
If I evaluate it for 200, I know
it for 1/200, and vice versa.
Our g function is
kind of like that.
Now, this function you
can see that starts
to go linearly increases with
x, and then eventually it
comes down like this
must have one maximum.
Where is the maximum?
It has to be 1.
I don't have to take derivatives
of everything, et cetera.
If there is one point which
corresponds to the maximum,
it's the point that
maps to itself.
Now, this function
for the Ising model,
I know it has a
phase transition.
Or, I guess it has
a phase transition.
So there is one point,
hopefully one point,
at which it becomes singular.
I don't know, maybe
it's three point.
But let's say it's one point
at which it becomes singular.
Then I should be able to figure
its singularity by precisely
the same argument.
So the function that corresponds
to x going to 1 over x
is this hyperbolic sine.
So if there is a point which
is the unique point that
corresponds to the
singularity, it
has to be the point that is
self-dual-- maps on to itself,
just like 1.
So sine of 2 Kc should be 1.
And what is this?
Hyperbolic sine we can
write as e to the 2 Kc
minus e to the
minus 2 Kc over 2.
We can manipulate
this equation slightly
to e to the 4 Kc minus 2 e to
the 2 Kc minus 1 equals to 0,
which is a quadratic
equation for e to the 2 Kc.
So I can immediately solve
for e to the 2 Kc is--
This has a 2, so I can say
1 minus plus square root
of square of that plus this.
So that is a square root of 2.
The exponential
better be positive,
so I can't pick the
negative solution.
And so we know--
AUDIENCE: Isn't it [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Where did I-- OK.
Multiply by e to the 2 Kc.
AUDIENCE: Taking that as
correct, I didn't check it--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK.
x squared minus 2b
plus-- x plus c equals.
Well, actually,
this is-- so x is
b minus plus square root
of b squared minus ac.
Our c is negative.
So it's 1 plus 1.
So the critical coupling
that we have is 1/2 log of 1
plus square root of 2.
So we know that the critical
point of the Ising model
occurs at this value, which
you can put on your calculator.
And it is something like this.
There is one assumption.
Of course, there is essentially
only one singularity.
And there is one singularity
in this free energy.
But if it is, we have
solved it for this case.
So I think to emphasize
this was discovered
around '50s by Wannier,
this idea of duality.
And suddenly, you had exact
solution for something
like the square Ising model.
Question is, how much
information does it give you?
First of all, the
property of self-duality
is that of the square lattice.
So if I had done this on
the triangular lattice,
you would've seen that
the low-temperature and
high-temperature
expansions don't match.
It turns out that in
order to construct
the dual of any lattice,
what you have to do
is to put, let's say, points
in the center of the units
that you have and see what
lattice these centers make.
So when you try to do that
for the triangular lattice,
you will see that the centers
form, actually, hexagonal
lattice, and vice versa.
However, there is a
trick using duality
that you can still calculate
critical points of hexagonal
and triangular lattice.
And that you will do in
one of the problem sets.
OK, secondly.
Again, that trick allows you
to go beyond square lattice,
but it turns out
that for reasons
that we will see
shortly, it is limited.
And you can only do
these kinds of dualities
to yourself for
two-dimensional lattices.
And what these kinds
of mappings in general
give for
two-dimensional lattices
is potentially, but not always,
the critical value of Kc.
And again, one of the
things that you will see
is that you can do this for
other models in two dimension.
For example, the
Potts model we can
calculate the critical point
through this kind of procedure.
However, it doesn't
tell you anything
about the nature
of the singularity.
So essentially, what we've
shown is that on the K-axis,
there is some point maybe
that describes the singularity
that you are going to have.
But the shape of this
singularity, the exponent
can be anything.
And this mapping does not
tell you anything about that.
It does tell you one thing.
We also mentioned that
the ratio of amplitudes
above and below for
various singular quantities
is something that
is universal because
of these mappings
from high temperatures
to low temperatures.
Although I don't know what the
nature of the singularity is,
I know that the amplitude
ratio is [INAUDIBLE].
So there is some
universal information
that one gains beyond the
non-universal location
of the critical point,
but not that much more.
OK.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible
to extract from this line
a differential equation for g?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And indeed, that
differential relation
you will use in
one of the problem
sets that I forgot
to mention, and will
be used to derive the value
of the derivative, which
is related to the energy of the
system at the critical point.
But you are right.
This is such a beautiful
thing that maybe we
can try to force it to
work in higher dimensions.
So let's see if we
were to try to go
with this approach for the 3D
Ising model what would happen.
So what did we do?
We wrote the low-temperature
series, high-temperature series
and compared them.
Again, let's do
the cubic lattice,
which I will not
really attempt to draw.
That's the system that
we want to calculate.
So let's do the low T-series.
Our partition function is
going to start with the state
where every spin
is, let's say, up.
Three bonds per site
on the cubic lattice.
So it's 3 NK.
Again, the trivial degeneracy of
2 for the two possible all plus
or all minus states.
The first excitation
is to flip a spin.
So any one of N sites could have
been flipped, creating a cube.
A cube has 6 faces that go
out, so there is essentially
6 bonds that are broken.
So basically,
there is this minus
that is in a box
surrounded by plus.
And as you can see, 6 plus
minus 1 that go out of that.
The next one would be
when we have 2 minuses.
And that can be oriented three
ways in three dimensions.
e to the minus 2K.
1, 2 times 4.
8 plus 2.
Times 10.
And so the general
term in the series I
have to draw some droplet of
minuses in a sea of pluses.
And then I would have e to the
minus 2K times the boundary
or the area of this droplet.
Actually, droplets
because there could
be multiple droplets
as we've seen.
There's no problem with that.
If I do the high T, follow
exactly the procedure
I had described before,
partition function is going
to be 2 to the number of sites.
Cosh K to the power of the
number of bonds and there
are 3 bonds per site.
So there's 3N there.
And then we start to
draw our diagrams.
The first diagram
is just exactly
like what we had before.
I have to make a square.
And this square can be placed
on any face of the cube.
And there are 3 faces
that are equivalent.
The next type of diagram that
I can draw has 6 bonds in it.
So this could be
an example of that.
And if you do the counting,
there are 18N of those.
And so you go.
And the genetic
term in the series
is going to be some
find of a loop.
Again, even number of bonds
per site is the operative term.
And then I have t to the
power of the number of bonds
making this closed loop.
Or loops.
So you stare at
the series and you
see immediately that
there is no correspondence
like we saw before.
The coefficient here are 1N, 3N.
Here, there are 1, 3, and 18N.
Powers are 6, 10.
Here are 4, 6.
There's no correspondence
between these two.
So there is nothing
that one could say.
But you say, I really like this.
So maybe I'll phrase the
question differently.
Can I consider some
other model whose
high-temperature
expansion reproduces
this low-temperature
expansion of the Ising model?
So this is the
question, can we find
a model whose high T
expansion reproduces
low T of 3D Ising model?
So rather than knowing
what the model is,
now we are going to
kind of work backward
from this graphical
picture that we have.
So what would have been
the analog thing over here,
let's say that I had
this picture of droplets
in the 2D Ising model.
I recognize that I need to
make these perimeters out
of something.
And I know that I can make these
things that are joined together
to a procedure such as the
one that we have over here.
But the unit thing,
there it was the elements
that I had along the perimeter.
What is the
corresponding unit that I
have for the low temperature
series of the Ising model?
I have e to the minus 2K to the
power of the number of faces.
So first thing is
unit has to be a face.
So basically, what
I need to do is
to have a series, which is an
expansion in terms of faces,
and then somehow I can
glue these faces together,
like I glued these
bonds together.
So we found our unit.
The next thing that we
need is some kind of a glue
to put all of these
LEGO faces together.
So how did we join
things together here?
We had these sigmas that
were sitting by themselves.
And then putting
two sigmas together,
I ensured that when
I summed over sigma,
I had to glue two
of the T's together.
Can I do the same
thing over here?
If I put the sigmas on the
corners of these faces,
you can see it doesn't work
because here I have three.
So I'm forced to put the
sigmas on the lines that
join the faces.
So what I need to
do is, therefore,
to have a variable
such as this where
I have these sigmas
sitting on the-- let's call
this a plaquette, p.
And this plaquette
will be having
around it four different bonds.
And if I have the product
of these four bonds--
again, these sigmas
being minus plus 1--
I am forced to glue
these sigmas in pairs.
And I can join these things
together, these squares,
to make whatever shape that
I like that would correspond
to the shapes that
I have over there.
So what I need to do is to have
for each face a factor of this.
So this is the analog of this
factor that I have over here.
And then what I
need to do is to do
a product over all plaquettes.
And I sum over all sigma tildes.
And this would be the partition
function of some other system.
In this other
system, you can see
that if I make its
expansion, there
will be a one-to-one
correspondence
between the terms in the
expansion of this partition
function and the 3D Ising
model partition function.
Again, this kind of
term we have seen.
If I had put factors of cosh
here, which don't really
do much, I can re-express as
e to the something-- k tilde
sigma 1p sigma 2p
sigma 3p sigma 4p.
Essentially every time
you see 1 plus t times
some binary variable, you can
rewrite it into this fashion.
So what we have come up
with is the following.
That in order to
construct the dual
of the three-dimensional
Ising model, what we do
is you go all over your cube.
On each bond of it, you put a
variable that is minus plus 1.
So previously for
the Ising model,
the variables were
sitting on the sites.
So Ising, these
were site variables.
Whereas, this dual Ising,
these are the bond variables
that are minus plus 1.
In the case of the
Ising, the interactions
were the product of
sites making on a bond.
Whereas, for the dual
Ising, the interactions
are around the face.
There's four of them
that go around the face.
But whatever this
new theory is, we
know that its free energy
because of this relation
is related to the free energy
of the three-dimensional Ising
model.
Also, we know that the
three-dimensional Ising model
has a phase transition
between a disordered phase
and the magnetized phase
at low temperature.
There is a singularity.
As I span the parameter K of the
three-dimensional Ising model,
there is a Kc.
Now, I can find
out what that Kc is
because I don't
have self-duality.
But I know that as I span the
parameter K of the Ising model,
I'm also spanning the parameter
K tilde of this new theory.
And since the original model
has a phase transition,
this new model must also
have a phase transition.
So there exists a
Kc for both models.
You say, OK.
Fine.
But there is some complicated
kind of Ising model
that you have devised and
it has a phase transition.
What's the big deal?
Well, the big deal is
that this model is not
supposed to have a phase
transition because it
has a different
type of symmetry.
The symmetry that we
have for the Ising model
is a global symmetry.
That is, the energy
of a particular state
is the energy of the state
in which all of the spins
are reversed.
Because the form of
the energy is bilinear.
If I take all of the sigmas
from one configuration
and make them minus
in that configuration,
the energy will not change.
But I have to do that globally.
It's a global symmetry.
Now, this model has a local
symmetry because what I can do
is I can pick one of the sites.
And out of this site,
there are six off
these bonds that are
going out on which
there is one of
these sigma tilde.
If I pick this site and I change
the sign of all of these six
that emanate from this site,
the energy will not change.
Because the energy gets
contributions from faces.
And you can see that for
any one of the faces,
there are two sigmas
that have changed.
So the energy, which is the
product of all four of them,
has not changed.
So this model has
a different form,
which is a local symmetry.
And in fact, it is very much
related to gauge theories.
It's a kind of discrete
version of the gauge theories
that you have seen
in electromagnetism.
Since there are
two possibilities,
it's sometimes called
a Z2 gauge theory.
Now, the thing about the gauge
theories is that there is
a theorem which states that
local or these gauge theories,
gauge symmetries, cannot
be spontaneously broken.
So for the case of
the Ising model,
we have this symmetry between
sigma going to minus sigma.
But yet, we know that if
I go to low temperature,
I will have a state in which
globally all of the spins
are either plus or minus.
So there is a
symmetry broken state
which is what we
have been discussing.
Now, the reason that that
cannot take place in these gauge
theories, I will just
sketch what is happening.
Essentially, we
have been thinking
in terms of this
broken symmetries
by putting an infinitesimal
magnetic field.
And we saw that, basically,
if I'm at temperatures of 1
over K's that are below
some critical value,
then if h is plus,
everybody would be plus.
If h is minus, everybody
would be minus.
And the reason as you approach
h goes to 0 from one site
that you don't get average of
0 is because the difference
between the energy of
this state and that state
as you go to 0 temperature
is proportional to N times h.
So although h is going to
0 with N being very large,
the influence of infinitesimal
h is magnified enormously.
Now, for the case of these
local gauge theories,
you cannot have a
similar argument.
Because if I pick this spin,
let's say one of these bond
spins.
And let's say is its
average-- what is its average?
As I said, the h going to 0.
Well, the difference
between a state
in which it is plus or the
state in which it is minus
is, in fact, 6h.
Because all I need
to do is to pick
a site that is
close to that bond
and flip all of the spins
that are close to that.
All of the K's are
equally satisfied.
The difference
between that state
and the one where there
is a flip is just 6h.
So that remains
finite as h goes to 0.
There is no barrier towards
flipping those spins.
So there is no broken
symmetry in this system.
So this can be proven very
nicely and rigorously.
So we have now two
statements about this Ising
version of a gauge theory.
First of all, we know
that at low temperatures,
still the average
value of each bond
is equally likely
to be plus or minus.
From that perspective of local
values of these bond spins,
it is as disordered as the
highest-temperature phase.
Yet, because of its duality
to the three-dimensional Ising
model, we know that
it undergoes some kind
of a singularity going
from high temperatures
to low temperatures.
So there is probably some
kind of a phase transition,
but it has to be very
different from any of the phase
transitions that we have
discussed so far because there
is no spontaneous
symmetry breaking.
So what's going on?
Now, later on in
the course, we will
see another example of
this that is much less
exotic than a gauge
theory, but it
has the same kind of
principle applicable to it.
There will be a phase transition
without local symmetry breaking
in something like a
superfluid in two dimensions.
So one thing that that phase
transition and this one
have in common is,
again, the lack
of this local-order parameter
from symmetry breaking.
And both of them
share something that
was pointed out by Wegner
once this puzzle emerged,
which is that one has to look
at some kind of a global-- well,
I shouldn't even call it global.
It is something that is
called a Wilson loop.
So the idea is the following.
That we have these
variable sigma tilde
that are sitting on
the bonds of a lattice.
Now, the problem is that with
this local transformations,
I can very easily make this
sigma go to minus sigma.
So that is not a good
thing to consider.
However, what was the problem?
Let's say I pick this site.
All of the sigmas that
went out of that site
I changed to minus themselves.
That was the gauge
transformation,
but it became minus.
But if I multiply the sigma
with another sigma that goes out
of that site, then I
have cured that problem.
If I changed this
to minus itself,
this changes, this changes.
The product remains [INAUDIBLE].
But then I have
the problem here.
So what I do is I
make a long loop.
I look at the expectation value.
So this Wilson
loop is the product
of sigma tilde around a loop.
And what I can do is I
can look at the average
of that quantity.
The average of that
quantity is something
that is clearly invariant
to this kind of gauge
transformation.
So the signatures of a
potential phase transition
could potentially be revealed by
looking at something like this.
But clearly, that
is a quantity that
is always also going
to be positive.
So the thing that
I am looking at
is not that this quantity
is, say, positive
in one phase and 0
in the other phase.
It is on how this
quantity depends
on the shape and
characteristics of these loop.
So what I can do is I can
calculate this average, both
in high temperatures and low
temperatures, and compare them.
So if I look at-- let's starts
with, yeah, high temperatures.
The high-temperature expansion.
So I want to calculate
the expectation
value of the product of
sigma tilde, let's call it i,
where i belongs to
some kind of a loop c.
So c is all of these bonds.
I want to calculate
that expectation value.
How do I calculate
that expectation value?
Well, I have to sum
over all configurations
of this product with a weight.
What is my weight?
My weight is this
factor of product
over all plaquettes of 1 plus
t sigma tilde sigma tilde sigma
tilde for the plaquette.
So this is the
weight that I have.
I can put the hyperbolic
cosine or not put it,
it doesn't matter.
But then this weight has
to be properly normalized.
It means that I have
to divide by something
in the denominator,
which basically does not
include the quantity
that I am averaging.
So the graphs that
occur in the denominator
are the things that we
have been discussing.
Essentially, I start with 1.
The next term is to put
these faces together
to make a cube, and then
more complicated shapes.
That, essentially,
every bond is going
to be having some
kind of a complement.
Well, but what about the
terms in the numerator?
For the terms in
the numerator, I
have these factors
of sigma tilde
that are lying all
around this loop.
And I'm summing over
the two possible values.
So in order that summing
over this does not give me 0,
I better make sure that there
is a complement to that.
The complement to that
can only come from here.
So for example, I would
put a face over here
that ensures that that is
squared and that is squared.
But then I have this one.
Then I will put
another one here.
I will put another
one, et cetera.
And you can see that the
lowest-order term that I would
get is this factor that
characterize each one of them.
Raised to the power of
the area of this loop c.
You can ask higher-order terms.
You can kind of build
a hat on top of this.
This you can put
anywhere, again,
along this area of this thing.
So the next correction in
this series you can see
is also going to be something
that will be 1 plus t
to the fourth times the area.
The point is that as you
add more and more terms,
you preserve the structure
that the whole thing is going
to be proportional
to the area of loop
times some function
of this parameter t.
So what we know is that
if I take the expectation
value of this entity,
then it's logarithm
will be proportional
in high temperatures
to the area of this loop.
Now, what happens if I
try to do a low T-series
for the same quantity?
So I have to start
with a configuration
at low temperature that
minimizes the energy.
One configuration clearly is
one where all of the sigmas
are plus.
And that will give me a term.
If I am calculating
the partition function
in the denominator,
there will be
a term that will be
proportional to e to whatever
this K tilde is per face.
And there are three
faces of a cube.
There are N cubed,
so there will be
3K tilde N for the
configuration that is all plus.
But this is not the only
low-temperature configuration.
That is what we were discussing.
Because I can pick
a site out of N site
and the 6 bonds
that go out of it,
I can make minus themselves.
And the energy would
be exactly the same.
So whereas the Ising model,
I had a multiplicity of 2.
Here, there is a
multiplicity of 2 to the N.
So that's the lowest term in
the low-temperature expansion
of the partition function.
I'm doing the
partition function,
which is the denominator first.
Then, what can I do?
Then, let's say I start with a
configuration where all of them
are pluses.
There are, of course, 2 to
the N gauge copies of that.
So whatever I do to
this configuration,
I can do the analog
in all of the others.
But let's keep the copy where
all of the sigmas are plus,
and then I flip one of
the sigmas to minus.
Then, it's essentially--
think of a cube.
There is a line that was
plus and I made it minus.
There are four faces going out
of that that were previously
plus K, now become
minus K. So I will
have 2K tilde times 4
because of these four things
that are going out.
And the bond I can orient
in x-, y-, or z-direction.
So there are 3N possibilities.
And so I could have a series
such as this in the denominator
where subsequent terms would
be to put more and more
minus in this
particular [INAUDIBLE].
Now, let's see how these
series would affect the sum
that I would have to do in order
to calculate this expectation
value.
For any one of these
configurations,
since I am kind of looking
at the ground state,
let's say they're all pluses.
Clearly, the contribution to
this product will be unity.
That does not change.
But now, let's think
about the configurations
in which one of the
bonds is made to flip.
As long as that
bond does not touch
any of the bonds that
are part of the loop,
the value of the loop
will remain the same.
So let's say that
the loop has P sites.
So this is number of bonds in c.
Let's call it Pc.
For these, with this weight,
the value of Wilson loop
would still be plus.
But for the times where I
have picked one of these
to become minus, then the
product becomes minus.
So for the remaining Pc
times of this factor,
e to the minus 2K
tilde times 4, rather
than having plus
I will have minus.
So you can see
that-- what is this?
N should be up here.
That the difference between
what is in the numerator
and what is in the denominator
of this low-temperature series
has to do with the
bonds that have
been sitting as part
of the Wilson loop.
And if I imagine that
this is a small quantity
and write these as
exponentials, you
can see that this
is going to start
with e to the minus
2K tilde times 4 times
the perimeter of this cluster.
Of this loop.
And you can go and look at
higher and higher order terms.
The point is that
in high temperature,
the property of the shape
of the loop that determines
this expectation
value is its area.
Whereas, in the low-temperature
expansion, it is its perimeter.
So you could, for
example, calculate
the-- for a large loop,
the log of this quantity
and divide it by the perimeter.
And in the low-temperature
phase, it would be finite.
In the high-temperature
phase, it
would go to 0 because
the area scale
is bigger than the perimeter.
So we have found something
that is an analog of an older
parameter and can distinguish
the different phases,
and it is reflected in the
way that the correlations take
place.
Let's try to sort of think about
some potential physics that
could be related to this.
Let's start with the gauge
theory aspect of this.
Well, the one gauge theory
that you probably know
is quantum electrodynamics,
whose action
you would write in
the following way.
The action would involve
an integration over space
as well as time.
And by appropriate
rescalings, you
can write the energy that is
in the electromagnetic field
as d mu A mu minus d
mu A mu squared, where
A is the 4-vector potential
out of which you can construct
the electric field
and magnetic field.
And the reason this
is a gauge theory
is because if I take A and
add to it some function of phi
of x and t, as long as
I take the derivative
of this function, you can
see that the change here
would be d mu d mu
minus d mu by d mu.
There is really no change.
And we know that
basically you can
choose whatever
value of this phase--
this gauge fixing
potential over here.
Now, this is the
electromagnetic field by itself.
If you want to couple it
to something like matter
or electrons, you
write something
like i d bar, which
is some derivative,
and then you have e A bar.
If there's a mass to this
object, you would put it here.
This would be something
like psi bar psi.
that would describe
the coupling of this
electromagnetic field
to some charged particle,
such as the electron.
And this entire thing satisfies
the gauge symmetry provided
that once you do this, you
also replace psi with e
to the ie phi psi.
So the same phi, if it appears
in both, essentially the change
in A that you would
have from here
will be compensated
by the change
that you would get from the
derivative acting on this phase
factor.
And so the whole
thing is not affected.
What we have constructed
in this model
is kind of an Ising
analog of this theory.
Because the Hamiltonian
that we have,
which carries the weight
after exponentiate
of the different
configurations, has a part
which is the sum over all of the
plaquettes of this sigma tilde
sigma tilde sigma
tilde sigma tilde,
the four bonds
around the plaquette.
We could put some kind of a
coupling here if we want to.
And the analog of
this transformation
that we have-- well, maybe it
will become more apparent if I
add the next term, which is
the analog of the coupling
to matter.
If I put a spin and
then sigma tilde ij sj.
So again, imagine that we
have our cubic lattice,
or some other lattice, in which
we have these variables sigma
tilde that are
sitting on the bonds.
And the first term is the
product around the face.
And the second term
I put these variables
s that are sitting here.
And I have made a coupling
between these two s's.
So if the sigma
tildes were not there,
I could make an Ising model
with s's being plus or minus,
which are coupled across
nearest neighbors.
What I do is that the
strength of that coupling I
make to be plus or
minus, depending
on the value of the
gauge field, if you like.
This Ising gauge field
that is sitting over there.
Now, the analog of these
symmetries that we have for QED
is as follows.
I can pick a particular s i
and change its value to minus.
And I can pick all of the sigma
tildes that go out of that i
to the neighbours and
simultaneously make them minus.
And then this energy
would not change.
First of all, let's
say if I pick this site
and change its face from
being plus or minus,
then the bonds that-- the
sigma tildes that go out of it
will change their values
to minus themselves.
Since each one of the
faces contains two of them,
the value of the energy
from here is not changed.
Since the couplings to the
neighboring s's involve
the sigma tildes that
sit between them,
and I have flipped
both s and sigma tilde,
those do not change
irrespective of what
I do with the face of
all the other ones.
So I have made an Ising,
or binary version,
of this transformation,
constructed
a model that has, except
being Ising symmetry,
a lot of the properties
that you would
have for this kind of action.
Now again, continuing with that,
this difference between why
we see an area rule
or a perimeter rule
has some physical consequence
that is worth mentioning.
And this, again,
has not much to do
with the main thrust
of this course,
but just a matter of
overall education.
It is useful to know.
So in this picture, where
one of the dimensions
corresponds to time,
imagine that you
create a kind of a
Wilson loop which
is very long in one
direction that I
want to think of as being time.
And the analog of this
action that we have discussed
is to create a pair of charges,
separate them by a distance x,
propagate them for a long
time t, and then [INAUDIBLE].
And ask, what is the
contribution of a configuration
such as this to their
action on average?
And so you would say that if
particles are at a distance x,
they are subject to some
kind of a potential v of x.
And if this potential
has been propagated
in time for a
length or a duration
that I will call T, that
the effect that it has
on the system is to have
an interaction such as this
in the action propagated
over a time T.
So I should have
something like this.
So this should
somehow be related
to this average of the
Wilson loop in manner
to not be made precise,
but very rough just
to get the general idea.
And so what we have said is that
the value of this Wilson loop
has different
behaviors at high T
and low T in its
dependence on shape.
And that high temperatures, it
is proportional to the area.
So it should be
proportional to xT.
Whereas, in low temperature, it
is proportional to perimeter.
So it should be
proportional to x plus T.
So if I read off the form of V
of x from these two dependents,
you will see that V of
x goes proportionately
to x in one regime.
And once I divide
by T, the leading
coefficients-- so
this is essentially
I want to look at the limit
where T is becoming very large.
So this thing when I divide
by T goes to a constant.
And I can very
roughly interpret this
as the interaction
between particles
that are separated by x
via this kind of theory.
And I see that
for particles that
are separated by x in
that kind of theory,
there is a weak coupling--
high temperature
corresponds to weak coupling--
where the further apart I
go, the potential that
is bringing them together
becomes linearly stronger.
So this is what is
called confinement.
Whereas, in the other
limit of low temperatures,
or strong coupling,
what you find
is that the interaction
between them
essentially goes to a constant.
The potential goes
to a constant,
so the force would go to 0.
So they are asymptotically free.
So if I start with
this kind of theory
and try to interpret it in
the language of quantum field
theory as something that
describes interaction
between particles, I find that
it has potentially two phases.
One phase in which the
particles of the theory
are strongly bind
together, like quarks
that are inside the nucleus.
And you can try to
separate the quarks,
but they would snap back.
You can't have free quarks.
And then there is another phase
where essentially the particles
don't see each other.
And indeed, quarks
right inside the nucleus
are essentially free.
We can sort of regard
them as free particles.
So this theory
actually has aspects
of what is known as confinement
and asymptotic freedom
within quantum chromodynamics.
The difference is
that in this theory,
there is a phase transition
and the two behaviors
are separated from each other.
Whereas in QCD, it's
essentially a crossover
from one behavior
to another behavior
without the phase transition.
So we started by thinking
about these Ising models.
And we kind of
branched into theories
that describe loops, theories
that describe droplets,
theories that describe
gauge couplings, et cetera.
So you can see that that nice,
simple line of the partition
function that I have written
for you has within it
a lot of interesting complexity.
We kind of went
off the direction
that we wanted to go
with phase transitions,
so we will remedy
that next time, coming
back to thinking about how to
think in terms of the Ising
model, and try to do more with
understanding the behavior
and singularities of
this partition function.